(soldiers speaking foreign language)
(suspenseful music)
- [Johnny] There are bunkers
everywhere in this country.
- [Radio Controller] Mayday,
mayday, mayday, slowing down.
(radio controller speaking
faintly) slowing down.
- [Announcer] Nevertheless,
their objective remains
the total conquest of all Germany.
(bombs exploding)
(ominous music)
(metal clacking)
(gentle ominous music)
- I'm currently inside
of the largest bunker
in all of Switzerland.
It is massive.
I mean, look at this place.
(Johnny chuckles)
(gentle ominous music)
30,000 square meters of space,
which is 300,000 square feet
for those imperial
people out there like me.
And I'm hanging out with Eric,
who currently owns the bunker.
- This is where the crew
was taking the showers,
showering 85 meters of rock above you.
- [Johnny] Yeah, it's gotta be
one of the deepest showers in the world.
He's been showing me giant cannons
and the sleeping quarters and the hospital
and the giant generators
that have provided
electricity for this place.
- Incredible.
(gentle ominous music)
(switch clicks)
(metal clinking)
- From the outside this thing
does not look big at all.
(Johnny laughing)
Wow. Look at that.
That is amazing.
A reminder that
every time you see a
little door in the forest
that goes into a bunker,
it's probably a massive
network of tunnels.
Two meters of concrete
here at the entrance.
You go inside of this door
and you are let into a labyrinth
of tunnels and weaponry.
- [Eric] Eight kilometers of walkways.
- [Johnny] Eight kilometers?
- [Eric] Yeah.
- Oh, and with the most gnarly doors
you've ever seen in your life.
They're quadruple fortified
with huge slabs of concrete.
- This is like two meters of concrete.
It sit behind there with a rifle
and be able to protect the entrances.
- Wow. No one is getting into
this bunker anytime soon.
(gentle plucky music)
I went to Switzerland to hunt for bunkers.
Fortresses drilled impossibly
deep into mountains
and cliffs and villages hidden from view,
but packing deadly power.
Oh, wow. I've seen so many bunkers.
You don't have to look
super hard to find them.
They're everywhere.
There's a bunker right here, look at this.
This is not a rock.
(metal clanking)
This is a door.
(birds tweeting)
These little doors in
the middle of the forest,
so unassuming, so benign,
but boy, if you knew what was inside.
Let's be clear, this isn't normal.
Most countries don't bore into mountains
as their defense strategy,
but Switzerland isn't
like other countries.
- When you live in Switzerland,
you never really have a sense of threat.
We're Switzerland, we're neutral, right?
Nothing gonna happen to us.
(ominous music)
- So instead of forming alliances
and sending troops they dug.
And the results are nearly 10,000 of these
scattered all throughout the country.
And that is what I have
been searching for.
(drone whirring)
Okay, okay, okay.
Where are you, my bunkers?
Ah, I see something down there.
That is not natural erosion on this cliff.
I keep looking for more
and more and I'm realizing,
there are too many for me to fly to.
Like, there are dozens up there.
This cliff is just riddled
with little windows,
totally primed and prepped
to just light up this entire valley
if there was an invading
army from the north.
Oh, and it's not just the mountains.
I also discovered hundreds
of thousands of bunkers
dug under Swiss homes,
a further expression of
the Swiss habit of digging
to remain neutral.
The bunkers are at the
center of a discussion
that is heating up as the
world becomes dangerous again.
So Switzerland is once again debating
what these bunkers mean to them
and what it means to be safe, secure,
and neutral in a changing world.
(upbeat ominous music)
(static sizzles)
(bells clanking)
(cows mooing)
Okay wait, before we continue this story,
I need to tell you about today's sponsor,
as we look at the beautiful
Swiss countryside.
Today's sponsor is NordVPN,
which is a longtime
supporter of this channel
and I'm very grateful for that.
I have been here in Switzerland traveling.
And when I travel,
my computer and all of my
accounts kind of freak out
because they think
I'm like someone logging
into all of my accounts
from a different country,
but it's really just me.
So what I do is I click one
button and I log on to NordVPN,
and it connects me to the
internet via the United States.
So all of my accounts work nicely.
This is a big deal if you've ever been in
the death loop of two-factor
authentication like,
can't send you a text message
'cause you're in a
different country anyway.
That is just one use case.
NordVPN can be used for a million things.
Not only can you connect to the internet
via the UK and watch Netflix UK,
being connected to the internet
is becoming like a minefield
of different threats.
Whether it's like phishing or
your password getting stolen
or just malicious trackers,
the internet is not as
safe as it used to be.
I love this because it just
operates in the background,
it's one button, you click it,
it just does all the things.
And right now they have a
30-day money-back guarantee.
If you don't like it,
you can get all your
money back within 30 days.
So go click the link in my description.
It's nordvpn.com/johnnyharris.
Clicking that link helps
support this channel,
but it also gets you in
on an exclusive deal that
is happening right now
where you get four months
of NordVPN for free.
Thank you NordVPN for
sponsoring this video
and making it possible for me to come here
and make this in-depth piece on bunkers.
It's like a dream come true.
Okay, I'm gonna get back to the road.
(air whooshing)
(gentle suspenseful music)
I'm on top of a mountain
overlooking a stunning view,
but I'm looking for a bunker up here.
It's on the wall of this cliff.
I think I need to fly
the drone to find it,
but it's raining.
That's a problem.
The fog's rolling in, I gotta be quick.
(plastic clicking)
Okay, up on the side of this cliff.
I know there's a bunker nearby.
(foliage rustling)
Oh god.
Jesus.
(foliage rustling)
(beep) Okay, that was too close.
(gentle suspenseful music)
All right, I think this
is my takeoff point.
(drone beeping)
(drone whirring)
Oh yeah, I see bunkers.
I see bunkers.
Oh, boy. (chuckling)
Just blending into the
side of this mountain.
Oh my god, look at this.
(suspenseful music)
I mean, just looking at these bunkers,
you start to realize how incredibly
ambitious of a feat this is
to drill into the side of a cliff
and decide to build an
entire network of tunnels
that are connected and well
armed and strategically placed
so that you can hit the
targets you want to hit.
Oh, look, there's another one.
Oh my god, look at this.
That is just at the base of this cliff.
Oh my goodness, and it's hidden.
The only reason I can see
it is because I am above it,
but if you're looking at it
straight on, you don't see it.
It blends in perfectly. Look at that.
There's one behind all
of these little facades.
They're just guns that are
hiding in the wall of this cliff.
(gentle pulsing music)
(Johnny exhales)
Okay, onto the next bunker.
(bright twinkly music)
(wind whipping)
By the 1800s,
the Swiss were really good
at digging into mountains,
building cable cars, trains.
They just, they got really good.
And that prowess for digging
became incredibly useful in the 1940s
when their situation looked like this.
Surrounded by fascist regimes
that are quickly taking over
Europe very effectively,
these two allies, Italy and Germany,
with Switzerland kind of
sandwiched right in the middle.
Neutral Switzerland wanted
to stay out of the war.
So they did whatever it took.
But one of the major things they did
when they wanted to stay neutral,
was they started digging.
(dramatic pulsing music)
They turned their mountains
into a literal giant fortress.
Yes, you heard me right.
They turned their
mountains into a fortress,
or I guess technically
if you're a military nerd, a redoubt.
Redoubt just means,
basically an impenetrable fortress
that is dug into the ground,
but redoubts usually look
like this, one fortress.
Switzerland wanted to turn
their entire Alpine region,
which is a huge part of their
country, into a giant redoubt.
I'm gonna explain to you the
strategy in just a second,
what the thinking was here,
because it's a little paradoxical
and weird and war is weird,
but the point is here
that they started digging and digging,
and started creating what
one historian has called
the biggest fortress in Europe.
(dramatic techno music)
(air whooshing)
(camera shutter clicking)
(wind whistling)
(dramatic techno music)
I'm at the base of the
Swiss Alps right now
and I'm in a village
that is very Switzerland.
It's got a lot of grass
and cows and barns,
but a few of these barns
like this one behind me,
have a little secret inside.
(bells clanging)
- Now, it lights up, and then opens.
- Wow. (laughs) What?
This gun is massive.
It has a range of 21 kilometers.
(Johnny laughs)
And this is just one of four barn bunkers
that are all connected to
each other in this village.
- [Owner] We're going down here.
- [Johnny] So now we're in the tunnels.
Oh my gosh, wow.
- [Owner] Oh, yes.
- So we're just walking under
the green grass and the cows right now?
- [Owner] Exactly.
(suspenseful music)
- [Johnny] Oh my goodness.
- [Owner] And the grenades.
This 10.5 centimeter grenades.
(metal scraping)
You have to use this shell for
(shell clunks)
And the explosion sinks in
and the whole thing looks like that, huh?
- [Johnny] Oh, it's a good giant bullet.
- Yeah. First grenade in
and then the shelve in.
(bombs exploding)
Shows to the people that
they have to be quiet
to protect all our army secrets.
A lot of people and the
soldier say, "Hey, keep quiet."
All top secret.
(gentle music)
(foliage rustling)
- Switzerland turning their
country into a giant fortress
was basically made possible
because of these giant natural
walls that they already have.
If you're an invading army,
you can't get a bunch of
men over these mountains,
but these walls had gates in them.
Those gates are called mountain passes.
And when you're not in wartime,
mountain passes are actually really good.
Do you see that bridge behind me?
That bridge has been used for a long time
to let people flow throughout this pass,
but if you're Switzerland in 1942,
these gateways through the Alps
that have been used for
trade are now a liability.
They're now a gateway for invading armies
to come take over your country.
(motorcycle engine revving)
(indistinct chattering)
So this is where they
focus their attention.
All these choke points,
all of these gateways to their mountains.
The idea was if the Italians
start coming from that way
or the Germans start coming from that way
they can sit in their bunkers
and blow the smithereens out
of anyone coming up this pass.
Because again, it's a choke point.
No one can go anywhere else.
You can't go over the mountains.
You have to go through this pass.
(gentle music)
(dramatic techno music)
(car engine revving)
All right, I'm down from the
mountains for a little bit
and it's because I got invited
to hang out with this guy.
He's a retired Swiss historian
who's freaking obsessed
with maps of Switzerland.
I've never felt so seen in my life.
- I'm a an artillery gunner.
I did my basic training in a fortress.
And then we went here just for training.
Zurich in the pre Alps.
- He's showing me with
this amazing 3D relief map
what this fortress actually looked like.
- Here in these high mountains,
were several very very
important fortresses.
Some here, there were old
ones and some modern new ones.
Here, here, and even here.
Here there are bankers
and there is Toblerone.
Do you understand?
- Yes. I saw the Toblerone
on the summer the Southern-
- Toblerone.
There is a last Toblerone
and also here is one.
When France was defeated
in the summer 1940,
Switzerland was surrounded by the axis.
This was let's say, an emergency solution.
This was to redoubt.
(gentle ominous music)
- Okay, so I hike up to this Swiss house
in the middle of the Pass.
Looks like just a normal
Swiss house, is beautiful,
but you look closely
and you see something.
These windows aren't real
windows they're painted on.
This thing is actually solid concrete.
This is not a chalet.
These are not like barn doors.
Oh wait, are they gonna let me do this?
Oh my God. Oh my (laughs) God.
Look at this.
Those are just little gun holes.
Put your gun through that
thing and you can shoot.
(laughs) Oh wow, look at that.
This house is not just a house
with some gun holes in it.
It's actually a network of tunnels.
Hey, check this out.
I found a fake rock with a gun in it.
(Johnny laughs)
I was looking at this rock
and it looked a little weird,
a little off up close.
It looks like a real rock.
It's not.
Look under.
Yep. Oh yeah.
Boom, I see your secrets.
I've looked at enough bunkers
to know what the playbook is.
Hide something either in a
village or in a mountain.
Put a huge network of tunnels under it
and just point at the Pass
(guns firing)
and get ready to fire in
case there's an invasion.
(gentle ominous music)
But wait a minute, let's
examine the logic here.
Yeah, it's really cool to have mountains
full of really protective
bunkers, really cool,
but most people in Switzerland
do not live in the mountains.
Most people live up here
on this flat plateau
and in their early 1940s,
they were sitting ducks.
The point here was not to
protect the people directly
but rather to signal
to Hitler and Mussolini
that if they wanted to
connect their two empires
they would have to go through the Alps
and that that would be incredibly costly
and basically impossible.
It's like using defense as the deterrent.
Oh, and it worked.
The Nazis had a plan all fleshed
out to invade Switzerland
but they never did it.
And yes, that is not just
because of these bunkers.
It is because Switzerland was
letting the Nazis store money
and stolen stuff in their banks,
trading with them et cetera.
The bunkers were a part
of the deterrent strategy,
but the Swiss really paned to the Nazis
as another form of staying neutral,
something they hear a lot
about even 70 years later.
(gentle music)
I'm at a dam and if my intel is right
that big giant mountain behind
me is actually a bunker.
(drone whirring)
And away.
(dramatic music)
I don't see anything.
Wait a minute, yes I do.
What is that? What is that?
I see you big boy.
You are a very well hidden gun.
Wow. That thing blends in very nicely.
With that as their fortress,
no one can fire back.
(dramatic music)
Another hidden bunker, another
successful drone flight.
Nice job drone.
Let's get outta here.
Onto the next one.
(bright twinkly music)
I hear there's a tunnel up there
at the top of that mountain,
that foggy, foggy, wet mountain.
Three and a half kilometers.
I can do this. Let's go.
(bright twinkly music)
By the way, big thanks to the subscriber
who recommended this bunker to me.
I put a call out to ask Swiss people
what bunkers I should go hunting for,
and this is one of them.
(bright twinkly music)
(Johnny exhales sharply)
Wow.
(gentle suspenseful music)
So yeah, Hitler never invaded,
Switzerland stayed neutral in the war,
but eventually the Swiss
government was like,
"Why are we paying for a bunch of bunkers
"that we designed for Hitler?"
So they decided to decommission them.
(gentle suspenseful music)
A lot of them are totally abandoned,
but then you have private buyers,
people who have bought them
to turn them into whatever they want.
A lot of these are museums
or are owned by like
military organizations
that wanna preserve the history,
but some people get really
creative with these bunkers.
Like people are growing mushrooms
and fermenting cheese in them,
or perhaps my favorite use
the place I slept last night.
(gentle music)
This is my hotel tonight.
I booked this hotel
because I'm making a story about bunkers.
And so I was like, "I have
to stay in a bunker hotel."
I had no idea it was gonna be this.
This is a full blown deep
in the mountain bunker.
There's dripping water everywhere.
Original ladders.
This place is nuts.
(gentle music)
Okay, I guess I'm gonna go
get dinner in this bunker.
There's a restaurant in it.
I'm going there now.
(gentle music)
What is happening?
- [Announcer] Switzerland is
one of the beautiful countries
in the world.
This small countries
surrounded by powerful nations
has been able to remain
neutral for the past 150 years.
150 years, 150 years.
(bright twinkly music)
- And I'm back in the city
and I need to tell you
the next part of the story
because this is where it
becomes relevant to today.
- [Announcer] The Swiss
people have always been ready
to protect their country.
- After the bunker digging
strategy worked in World War II
to keep Switzerland neutral,
they kind of latched onto the idea,
digging bunkers worked and they
weren't gonna stop doing it
but the Nazi threat went away
and was replaced with a new threat.
One that would not be deterred by
turning your mountains
into a giant fortress
(bright twinkly music)
(military air raid sirens)
- [Announcer] That signal means
to stop whatever you are doing
and get to the nearest safe place fast.
- [Announcer] It is called a
Cold War because armed forces,
although used as a threat,
are rarely unleashed.
- While the rest of the world
was busy making alliances
and arming themselves,
the Swiss turned to their
good old strategy of digging,
but instead of focusing on the mountains
they turned to the city.
I've been hanging out with Robin,
a Swiss journalist who's
been showing me around
the non-mountain version of Swiss bunkers.
- So this is like a normal basement
usually in a Swiss house.
And then behind here you
mostly have this thick door,
is really nothing special,
it's just a regular seller.
What we do as Swiss people,
we store golf clubs,
we store skis, wine, but of
course with a special window,
with a special filter.
So we close this.
- [Johnny] Oh my gosh.
- Yep. Like this.
- [Johnny] Yep. Wow.
- And then like this.
- It's gotta be funny that
American comes to town
and is like, "Look at these bunkers."
And you're just like-
- "No Johnny, it's just a seller."
(both laughing)
- It's a seller.
There's nothing special.
And I'm like, "But the door is so thick."
So you're Switzerland in the 1950s
your big alpine fortress
digging bunkers thing worked.
And you're like,
"Let's make everyone have
a bunker in their house
"so that we can be protected
against nuclear apocalypse."
Okay, cool idea in theory.
In practice, incredibly
impractical and very expensive.
So they did what they do
for just about everything in Switzerland,
they put it to a vote.
(gentle ominous music)
And so in the '60s they
decreed bunkers as a right.
They actually lined out
exactly how to build bunkers.
They required everyone to build them
either retroactively or
in their new buildings.
And the Swiss government would pay like
70% of the cost for these bunkers.
The people would be protected
using the same strategy
that they've always used,
digging holes.
(dramatic pulsing music)
So I went to the factory of
a company that makes bunkers
the beds and the dry toilets
and the air ventilation.
I feel like I'm wandering through the Ikea
for bomb shelters. (laughs)
(dramatic pulsing music)
And perhaps my favorite,
these giant doors.
Oh my god, these giant doors.
I've fallen in love with these doors.
I don't know why.
They're just large.
They're really fun to push and pull
and they're just kind of cartoonish
because they're so freaking thick.
Oh my god, look at that door.
Oh my god, look at this thing.
Oh yeah, wow.
- It's nothing-
- This is nothing special.
- No. No.
(both laughing)
- Oh, and they always have
like this yellow wrench
that I've become very attached
to, the yellow wrench.
Oh, you see a yellow wrench
and there's a bunker.
It's like safety or something.
I don't know.
Can I buy one of these as a souvenir?
I've wanted one forever.
Oh my goodness. I have a yellow wrench.
I've always wanted one.
Thank you.
The bunker industry's been slowing down
since the end of the Cold
War, for obvious reasons.
And it's no longer required
by the building code
for new houses to have a bunker.
But unfortunately the Swiss bunker
is now getting a new wave of attention.
(journalist speaking in foreign language)
- [Journalist] As the
assault closes in on Kyiv,
two and a half million civilians
are suddenly on the front line.
- Putin's invasion of Ukraine
is changing everything.
The fear and the risk
of having to use a bunker
like this is increasing.
- It's crazy. I mean,
when the war started,
I've got phone calls and emails daily.
Interesting, mainly from Germans,
90% of Germans would call.
In Switzerland We have 11 million
more than there are people
underground nuclear shelters
and Germany there's zero.
So I got calls daily
from people from Germany,
"Can I rent a room here."
(speaking in foreign language)
- People are thinking
about their bunkers again.
The government is inspecting them
making sure they have enough.
(speaking in foreign language)
I'm in a giant neighborhood bunker
that is for anyone on this
neighborhood block to come to
in case of an emergency.
It's fully decked out as expected,
and it even has a
full-blown operating room
and a room for dead bodies.
(gentle suspenseful music)
Like that's what that is back there.
Putin's invasion of
Ukraine changed everything
for a lot of places in the world,
but here in Switzerland
it didn't only change how people think
about bunkers and physical safety,
but it also kicked off a debate
about the complex topic
of Swiss neutrality.
- The Swiss government says it is adopting
the EU sanctions package on Russia.
That's a huge move.
- This is Switzerland.
Who may I remind you did not take a side
when they came to Hitler.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Swiss president, Ignazio Cassis, said,
"Extraordinary times called
for extraordinary measures."
- Joining in on sanctions
for a lot of people
is a massive violation
of the thing that has kept them neutral
and peaceful for like 200 years.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Several parties saying,
"well, we should be more flexible."
More traditional party saying
"Well, neutrality means
not doing anything,
"not joining any party,
not helping anything,
"but rather offer (speaking
in foreign language)."
I don't how you say...
(bright twinkly music)
- Now, we took over the
sanctions from the EU
which basically makes us a war party.
Well, I don't like it. I
don't think it's right.
- If you're from a country
that isn't obsessively neutral
you're kind of like, "Dude,
you gotta take a stance."
But here they think differently
about the right side
and the cost of choosing
a side in conflict
or more importantly, the
benefit of not choosing a side.
- I think the Swiss,
the people themselves want
neutrality which we never know.
I mean, the majority rules.
It's democracy.
(bright twinkly music)
- Okay, well, that's it.
That is my journey.
I have to say, this story left
a bit of an impression on me.
I came here thinking I
was gonna go hiking around
and stumble upon some abandoned
bunkers in the forest,
but as I dug into this,
I found myself understanding
Switzerland in a new way.
This place where the people
didn't colonize other countries
but stayed here digging in their mountains
so obsessively to defend
their ideas about neutrality.
A neutrality that is finding new meaning
in a changing world.
Thanks for watching.
(bright twinkly music)
Hey, so I filmed so much more
than was put into this video.
Boy, the work has just begun.
Oh, I'm the drone.
It's kind of scaring me right now.
(upbeat music)
It's old, it's kind of broken,
it's not as good and...
(metal clinking)
(upbeat music)
I used to hear a lot about the American...
Oh, shit. (beep)
This is what it takes to get a bunker.
Oh, (beep)
Okay, I gotta go find that drone.
It's almost a travesty.
So much so that I'm finally done
not doing behind the scenes.
I'm gonna start putting a
bunch of BTS up on Patreon.
Patreon is a place that
I turn to for support
in a world where I'm trying to do deeper
more factually correct journalism
that is expensive and time consuming.
So over on Patreon I'm
gonna start to publish
behind the scene vlogs
or show you how all this stuff is made.
I'm also gonna publish a full version
of this tour that I did
through Eric's Bunker.
It's way longer and way cooler
than the two seconds I was
able to put in this video.
And going forward I'll be doing
behind the scenes stuff from the studio
and from my other travels
so that you can see how this is made.
You've been asking for it for a long time.
I've been resisting for some reason.
I'm done resisting.
Go become a Patreon and help
support independent journalism.
If you wanna support in other ways,
there's lots in presets
that are in the description.
And thank you Switzerland
for another amazing trip.
I'll see you soon.
(gentle ominous music)